Emperor Palpatine will return in Star
Wars Episode nine the rise of Skywalker
and he won't be stopping by for a cameo
despite what actor Ian McDermott might
say I have to be honest with you I was
in the area so I thought the least I
could do is to pop in for a laugh yeah
all joking aside speaking with IGN
Odysseus d23 Expo stars Daisy Ridley and
John boyega
and Kelly Marie Tran offered some
insight into the importance of the
dastardly figure who was famously
thought to have perished at the
conclusion of 1983 Star Wars Episode six
Return of the Jedi - the flicks story
fans were shocked when Palpatine's
distinctive laugh was heard at the end
of the first teaser trailer for rise of
Skywalker and it was made explicit that
this was no misdirection when the movies
first poster was revealed at d23
[Music]
the poster features the Emperor's
Vistage floating above Ridley's ray and
atom drivers kylo Ren as they face off
in a lightsaber duel in the same way
that his likeness looms over the posters
imagery boyega astutely pointed out that
Palpatine's machinations loom large over
the entire store war series he explained
I think the Emperor and his doctrine has
trickled down to so many of the
characters in the Star Wars universe and
that the dark side of the force is what
it is because of a lot of his actions
and plans and so to have him come back
he's like the greatest foe and greatest
enemy I mean we might as well take him
down properly Ridley similarly called
attention to the importance of the
character to the overall narrative of
the Skywalker saga and assured fans that
his reappearance after seemingly having
met his end at the hands of the redeemed
Anakin Skywalker was not a plot
development that was taken lightly by
the filmmakers Ridley said he's the
biggest baddie in Star Wars history now
that we've done the story I'm like it
couldn't have happened any other way
like it had to be that but he is very
you know instrumental to the plot of the
film it's not like he just appears again
it's all explained asked about her take
on the way director JJ Abrams and
company brought the epic 9 film saga to
its conclusion Ridley said I think it's
awesome when we were doing it I kept
going oh my god this is so cool and
that's nice to be in a film where you're
actually saying oh my god this is so
cool for her part it seemed to be all
Tran could do to keep from spoiling the
entire movie she said I mean I think
that there are so many themes in the
Star Wars films my favorite being
Redemption and this idea of like
whatever it comes at you you can well
I'm not gonna give you I'm not gonna
tell you what happens but the theme of
redemption pressed on exactly what her
comments meant in regards to Palpatine
Tran grinned mischievously and said
quotes look I don't know of course the
stars were also grilled over raised
seeming transformation and the new
footage from rise of Skywalker which was
screened at d23 said footage saw her
cloaked and hooded wielding a
distinctive dark mollusk red double
bladed lightsaber suggesting that before
it's all said and done the character
could be taking a walk on the dark side
a development which could be strongly
tied to Palpatine's return their
responses were right in line with their
previous remarks boyega's was
Trane's was carefully worded and
Ridley's was downright evasive after the
apparent dark rave reveal who Yaga quits
for me it's just a mere costume change I
mean the girl wanted dark I were black
sometimes doesn't mean I'm bad the red
it's a glowstick thing he also added I
don't think the fans should really get
into all of that well you need to look
at is how c-3po got his Golden Arm back
that's the question for me Tran when
asked about the reveal offered up this
cornucopia of vagueness saying I think
the most important thing to take from
that whole snippet is just that the
ending of this film is going to be
really really groundbreaking in a good
way I think there are a lot of little
pieces from the older films and
everyone's together in this one and it's
a really big we're gonna go out with a
bang Ridley while no more inclined
toward specificity did tease that the
rise of Skywalker will revisit the
themes of the previous films and putting
a bow on the Skywalker saga she revealed
I think the movies should hopefully show
people that we did a big old journey and
we explored some things so just you wait
till the film comes out thank you for
stating the obvious to find out for sure
how ray and friends wrap up their story
we'll just have to wait until star wars
episode 9 the rise of Skywalker hits
theaters on December 20th check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Applause]
[Music]